hey what's up everyone
welcome back to culture binge the
wisecrack podcast where we explore the
happenings of the current
cultural zeitgeist i'm michael here as
always with wisecracks alec how are you
doing today
i'm good how are you good and the poet
laureate
of the wisecrack intellectual community
serbia serbia what's happening with you
hi i'm well how are you oh doing just
peachy very excited to be back i think
we've had we've had quite
an extended vacation um since our last
episode so i'm glad everyone's doing
well any any big events happenings life
changes for anyone that every listener
should know about
still covet free still coverage would be
great
alec are you still covet-free covet-free
nightmares about having asymptomatic
covid and going to like
large gatherings without a mask on but
that's about it great
yes according to my unconscious mind i
am riddled with covid
all day but medically i think i am also
covet-free so
good to know all around um so a lot to
get into today
um but one big announcement is in 2021
we've decided to bring a certain dose of
negativity back to the podcast so
we will be reintroducing chaps
if if if one of the hosts wants to use
that we're not going to say it's
obligated if someone wants to say all
the way positive they can
but the full slaps and chaps protocol is
is back in play okay
so i just given giving listeners a
warning giving you all warning that said
let's get started with that serbia slaps
and chaps let's start with slaps
so slaps bridgerton on netflix slaps
um it's kind of cheesy but i love it
it's like gossip girl meets pride and
prejudice
i really enjoyed it uh the only thing i
didn't enjoy
uh were the sex scenes very
uncomfortable i was about to ask you
i saw someone who maybe posted video
clips on twitter and i thought it looked
like pretty pornographic
a little pornographic but also and and i
watched like a ton of stuff and i'm
super sex positive and those things
i watch a ton of porn i'm watching sex
23 hours a day watching this is too much
yeah it's off to the side um but i i've
watched game of thrones like nothing
ever really
makes me uncomfortable but for some
reason
these sex scenes like i had to forward
through them and i don't know if it's
because the girl looks
really young or um
they were just it was just like an
extended scene like it just went on and
on and on
and i didn't feel like it fit with the
show
like it felt like a totally different
vibe than the rest of the show
um so the context switching was really
uncomfortable but
i did not like the sex scenes but the
rest of it is really great um
was the dislike of the sex scenes a chap
internal to a slap or is there a
separate yeah you have to add to that
there is a second chapter okay
but yes that was that was an embedded
chap
uh a many things chap right now it's
difficult to narrow it down but this
week i'm gonna go
with the newest season of great british
bake off
oh good don't like the new host
they um they just changed the good guy
yeah he sexualizes baking
um wait is it no fielding no no the
there's another guy um matt lucas
i think um sandy sandy's not on this one
wait so is the theme that you don't like
british
sexualizations because bridgerton you
didn't like the british people having
sex
and british bake off you don't like that
the british people sexualize the baking
baking i think that you just don't want
any sexual activity
on the british island yeah yeah i mean
if everybody
in the uk could refrain from sexual
activity that would be
amazing you heard it here folks stop
reproducing britain
but really it was just like he makes
these gross comments like one of the
bakers
didn't have their like their bread
wasn't rising enough in the oven
and so he goes oh why don't you just
stroke it and maybe it'll get bigger
yuck yeah it's like stuff like that and
it just
doesn't fit with the vibe of bake off
which was supposed to be like charming
and delightful
and like just kind and he just goes by
and he seems to make the contestants and
the hosts uncomfortable as well
um it's just very disturbing and i don't
like it as much
i feel like the the old vibe and the old
like feeling
of fake off is gone now he kind of
reminds me of
when i was like in third grade i thought
it was funny to be annoying
um and like i think he just that's my
impression
is that he's just like it's still funny
to be annoying yeah
exactly wow um
i mean my takeaway still is like that
the british shouldn't be able to
sexualize anything give us what we want
which is neutered non-sexual culture you
guys um
but good i'm glad that was that was a
great chaps to re-inaugurate the
tradition um
alec how about you let's start with uh
slaps and then if you have one a chat
yeah uh slaps it's early on but i'm
gonna give a preliminary slaps i'm
reading this book
it's a cyberpunk novel called snow crash
it was recommended by one of our other
writers whose name is michael uh the
premise is that
there's a pizza delivery guy in the
future in a cyberpunk future where if
you don't get your pizza in 30 minutes
you can
kill the driver and like repossess the
car and also the pizza's free
also it's run by the mafia uh and so
it's [ __ ] nuts i'm only like
you know two chapters in but but so far
so good
as far as chaps uh
this might be controversial and i might
take back my opinion depending on how it
plays out i don't like one division i
don't i don't know what i'm supposed to
like about it
it seems like the thing to like about it
is a thing might happen
five episodes from now which i'm gonna
keep watching it and i might
change it but so far i do not care
what is one division it's a it's a
marvel
show with uh the scarlet witch who's
played by
elizabeth olsen and uh this guy named
vision who's also a superhero but he's
like a android kind of situation and
they uh exist within like the tv tropes
in the first episode of like
i would say like the honeymooners like
it's like it's a black and white episode
and the next episode is maybe
a little bit later like it seems like
it's maybe
in the 60s still black and white and
then it's like in color and so they're
just like embodying these tropes and
sort of replaying these but you don't
know
what these superheroes are doing in this
situation which is the intrigue
um but yeah
yeah as someone who liked it i don't
disagree with that take though and i
think it is a lot of the show is banking
on
uh are you reading into some of the
easter eggs assuming that certain things
might happen based on
super subtle clues like like words
in french on a wine bottle in the
background that hid to a line from like
a comic run from the mid-2000s so is
that true is that a
hint i missed yes um uh
it's i forget the exact name there's a
bottle of wine in the first episode that
refers to the
house of m from yeah so there's a lot
going on there in the background but i'm
yeah i'm curious to see what happens i
think i'm being too faithful maybe but
that's
i i'll be curious to revisit that chap
and see how it holds
yeah um what about you okay okay so what
slaps is
and i discovered this uh a couple weeks
ago so i guess this isn't super new but
do you guys know about the youtube
channel and instagram account
uh kart narcs no okay wow
where'd it begin um it's my new favorite
thing
in the world also as we record
apparently there was just an earthquake
um still looks okay
everything looks okay um carton arcs is
a uh
a series of videos where a man stakes
out parking lots and waits for people to
not return
shopping carts oh yeah um and then
questions them uh encourages them to do
it questions their morality and ethics
on the basis of them not doing this
simple activity that shows their moral
goodness the fundamental philosophy of
carton arcs seems to be that
you can evaluate one's moral fortitude
by what they're willing to do when no
one is watching and that the simple act
of returning a shopping cart
says a lot um some of the videos are
very funny there's one i that was
a recent one where a fireman doesn't
return his cart and the guy keeps asking
him to and then the fireman threatens to
to physically kill him
um i really like i'm someone that loves
rules and sort of like practical
morality so it really hits
a lot of sweet spots for me and i can't
believe i just found out about this
thing
i was just having a conversation about
our as a society we need more petty
punishment
i was doing this we were
volunteering at the park to clean up
trash and there's just people who
hang hang out there and drink and you
know that part's fine but there's like a
thousand bottle caps there
and like i don't want them to get a fine
i don't want i certainly don't want them
to get arrested or anything like that
but i was like i wish there was just
like
a petty punishment like next time they
do this or someone's job
is to find people littering in the park
and just like i'm gonna follow you
around
for the next four hours and play creed
and that's your punishment
and it's done and please don't do this
again but i think we need more things
like
confronting people about shopping carts
following people with annoying music
that kind of stuff
yeah i've recently uh the past couple
times i've been at the beach i've
noticed trash or people leaving trash
and it makes me
i'd say irrationally mad and makes me
think that anyone who would just go to
like
a beach or a hiking trail and just think
it's cool to leave trash is just a real
piece of [ __ ] and i can't
i can't imagine these are people that
have redeeming qualities in other areas
of their life
yeah so yeah so if you yeah go ahead
derby
so one thing i want to say about the
cart return um
some of my female friends don't
return carts sometimes when it's late at
night or
they just feel like there's like a guy
lingering so they'll put it near their
car
but it's more out of they just feel
unsafe rather than
i want to be an [ __ ] and like dump my
car i will say that
all the carton arcs videos i've seen
take place in broad daylight
um he is not i've never seen him shame a
woman who seems to be in that situation
so just
just to say from all i know of carton
arc's culture and
its inherent theological values i think
i have not seen that yet so
that makes perfect sense um let's see
i had two chaps i was going between i'll
do this one
my chap is there was a tweet going
around a week ago i'm not going to say
the name of the person
and it was a college professor who was
publicly mocking their students for not
properly addressing them in emails um
and then the basic just here is someone
was appalled
that when a student wrote them an email
didn't say hello professor blank or
hello dr blank
um i don't know as someone who was a
college professor for
almost a decade that's the biggest crock
of [ __ ] ever
who cares if the only reason you got a
phd is so that like
19 year olds and tons of debt and not
sleeping because of all their classes
like give you the
proper honor and emails like go f
yourself
um i just i just hate it so much and i
hate this idea that like
academia is meant to be some feudal
society where the young bow at the feet
of like the holy scholars the scholars
who in most cities
you know can't afford a mortgage so stop
acting like you're so special
um to be clear that's not their fault
society's fault but yeah i just it makes
me
so so um i so mad professor in college
who did that to me i
i greeted them as professor
so and so and she wrote back saying i
have a phd i worked really hard for that
so you need to call me doctor
i don't give a [ __ ] like really does it
matter i
i know yeah i hate it i know some
teachers
female teachers uh who might stress like
you need to address me as like either
professor or doctor but it's more of
like
all their male colleagues always get
assumed to be doctors whereas they're
like well what are you like some
i mean they're still an adjunct but you
know like basically not giving them the
respect and assuming that they don't
have like the credentials so to speak
but it's never like you need to give me
the proper
you know letter form email so that you
can stroke my ego just like
please acknowledge that i'm also a
doctor yeah well it's a full circle
this slaps and chap sessions we did
start off by criticizing the british
isles pretty hard um
for their attempts at sexuality i'll
praise them right now
uh because my my last like full-time
academic job was in the uk and in uk
academic culture
you just call people by their first
names so when i was in a department of
philosophy there
i was called michael and they're you
know one of my colleagues who was an
uh you know distinguished honored
professor blah blah blah her name was
allison like it wasn't this whole thing
where you
you talk like that and occasionally you
would see american
academics that assume that um i don't
like it and i think the what i noticed
the difference the difference of the
vibe of people just using your first
name is it was a lot more collegial
students felt a lot more comfortable
talking to you when they could just say
hey michael rather than excuse me
professor burns
um so yeah i hate that i think the
person who brought that up online is
dumb i think everyone who
who thinks that's a great way to do
things is dumb and i think you need more
meaning
value in your life if the only thing
that makes you feel powerful
is like that i don't know join like one
of those like fight gyms and do mma if
you want to feel powerful i guess
what was the response what did people
say to that this person got dunked on so
i mean i saw it too it was just like
yeah like this person's a monster
yeah there's like a couple early on
people that were like yeah but then the
internet
but also you're forgetting there was
there's a theatric component which was
she like walked in in the class and like
threw the papers everywhere and said
this is what
this is what it's like when you send me
an email without like a proper
like sanitation oh sorry these are week
old podcast notes everyone i'm really
sorry i
i left that detail out thank god that
alec is here but yes that's that that
made me even more infuriated that you
would do that especially to people who
for the most part like most students
are in debt most students are working
like 20 plus hours a week while taking
full-time classes
most students right now are doing all of
these things while living through a
goddamn global pandemic
so it's like maybe pump the brakes a
little bit dawg um
so yeah that's my thought on that but if
hey if you're a professor that wants to
be referred to as doctor or professor
please email us and we'll respond by not
calling you either of those things
but we got a lot to talk about today um
and lots of positivity i'm kidding we're
going to talk about a lot of covert
related things so get ready for it tuck
it
you know for yourself a cocktail if you
need to um so we're gonna talk about
uh the vaccination role today we're
gonna talk a little bit about the
relationship between
urban sprawl and covet cases in certain
cities
um and then we're gonna talk about you
know what it means if you are a uh
a white person from massachusetts who
decides that you are in fact spanish and
that you don't know what the word for
cucumber is and you have to ask the host
of the today show what you call that
um but maybe that was too much of a hint
um what it's a real thing that happens
or that happened um so i'll i'll start
let's talk about the vaccination roll
out a bit
i won't get too deep into this because i
know it's a bumper for everyone um
but the thing that we have been waiting
for the thing that we have hoped and
prayed for for months and months is
finally here
we have vaccines two of them approved so
far in america
that are available they're rolling out
and as we've been told all along
um by our government by those that work
at a thing called operation
warp speed that we would have millions
of vaccines administered by the end of
2020 going in 2021
and like none of this has happened um
and everything that's happened thus far
has been pretty shoddy so this is
as of a couple weeks ago um the united
states was on pace to have the entire
population vaccinated
in just under seven years um at the pace
we are currently operating and this this
is um starting from a place where we
were promised
not promised but told some level of
normalcy might be with us
um by autumn of this year so things off
to a bad start there
um one of the biggest things that's
that's been in the news and we've been
hearing about the vaccine robot is
unused vaccine doses which is it's
horrifying it's like
you show up at a party a little bit late
and you hear that someone had like a
chicken nugget tray but they decided at
9pm to throw all the nuggets away and
you're really hungry
and the nuggets are just in the trash
and you're like why did you do that yeah
i don't know if that's ever happened to
me but it would really upset me if it
did um
but because of the rules around who can
get vaccinated right now mixed with
um a little bit of confusion between
sort of the federal and state
governments and state and local
governments
there's been instances where at the end
of a given day
there are vaccine doses left and when
you open one of the vaccine containers
there's a ticking clock for how long you
have to use that and in some cases you
get to the end of the day they've maybe
already vaccinated everyone in the
facility that's over 75
there's doses left and i know in
california for example
and in new york people were worried
about punishment if you vaccinated
people that weren't in the tear that was
being vaccinated right then
so rather than nurses risk like paying
hefty fines
doses were thrown away um in other cases
and i think i read about this
um in new york yes there were some
nurses in new york that literally
ran around town trying to find qualified
people to give
shots to before it went bad and they
went to like a fire station and a few
other places
because they were just like well [ __ ]
like we have these doses to give out but
they were put in that situation
um so rules have recently changed now
um to at the federal level states level
that have opened it up to 65
plus which like sounded like a good
thing
but a lot of the things i have read uh
since then will argue that it's kind of
a bad thing and that by opening it up to
everyone 65 plus
it gives access to a lot of like
privileged people with access to good
medical care
that might not need it or people that
are already working from home and could
be taking doses away from people that
need it and work in high-risk situations
um there's a story and one could look
this up
about how stanford hospital um gave most
of the first round of their doses
to at administrative employees that
largely worked from home
and gave a very small amount of doses i
think it was 17 out of 1300 were given
to residents and
it led to a big stink there the
residents wrote this letter which you
can look up which is very good
where they pointed out how they
witnessed doses being given to people
they haven't physically seen in the
hospital since march because they've
been doing their admin work from home
while people you know and people who
were younger that were residents in the
hospital
who were exposed to covet every single
day were not able to get vaccines
um and then most recently i've heard
that in new york city this was according
to
um alex mayer that they are going to be
out of their doses as of
thursday the 21st of january so probably
after this podcast
comes out um so
a one quote i read this is by uh kevin
alt who's a professor at the university
of kansas medical center and this is
from a politico article
um he said and this is sort of the
argument against the opening it up based
on age criteria said if you open it up
and just base it on age criteria a lot
of people who already have access to
good health care can skip to the front
and leave other
people behind um so i think that's one
of the the big risks going on there
the only other thing i'll note from the
early stories and i know the story is
now a few weeks old but did you all hear
about the wisconsin pharmacist who
destroyed 500 doses just because yeah
yeah yeah um that was a fun one for us
because in my partner's extended family
there's a wisconsin pharmacist so we all
thought of course he did it he did
shouts to steve the wisconsin pharmacist
uh now in response to a lot of the the i
guess the bad parts of the rollout
um states have now started creating
massive vaccination centers
in california um dodger stadium is
becoming a
vaccination center so that's exciting
for all the disney adults out there
disneyland and orange county is becoming
a vaccine site so
you know we we we might hear wisecrack
occasionally be accused of going a
little hard on disney but i would say
this is an instance work that's a good
thing happiest place on earth
and then in alex neck of the woods met
stadium or what is it called something
else
it's the stadium where the mets play
city uh city field field city field
city fields um they're going 24 7 which
i think is great
and i'll say this as an aside something
that annoys me very bad why aren't they
all 24 7. i mean once we have the doses
for it
i would gladly get up at 3am to do that
or i would just stay up let's be honest
um the other thing that's also happened
um
in california and i'm pretty sure new
york and much of other places is along
with opening up these testing sites
um they've expanded who can be
vaccinators so
yeah i know in california for example
now like a dentist
is qualified to give you the vaccine i
heard that about new york as well
yeah um i've not yet heard if
youtube and podcast host are qualified
to give the vaccine but i've made calls
um so i'm hoping i'm gonna be able to
give out vaccines
um now the i guess one of the last
negative things i'll say and i'll see
what you guys think about this
um so even though there's been a lot of
talk about
how we don't have a lot of vaccine um
and i think our national reserve is
pretty much out and we're waiting for
the refill
in a lot of states um the percentages
that have been given out are still
pretty bad so the state as of right now
that's given out the most of their
vaccines are north dakota
um north dakota has given out i think
let me see
as of my last check 72.62 of the
vaccines they've been given have been
distributed
um so they're number one state of
california sorry i'm talking about it
but it's where i live
um it's where two-thirds of us live um
california is 45th in the nation uh
california's been given 3.5 million
doses they've administered 1.4 of those
um and yesterday the well yesterday
whenever we're recording this i don't
know when your yesterday will be
but uh gavin newsom of california kind
of bragged about how we've
given out the most doses without
pointing out the fact that we're the
have the largest state population and
have given out the
you know 45th least amount of them
um so things aren't going great uh
as we record this uh the united states
is experiencing a transfer of power
a peaceful one don't worry um
yeah but the new commander-in-chief has
promised to
give out a hundred million shots in his
first hundred days
um which i just want to say like that's
obviously better i'm not going to [ __ ]
on it but like
is that the best we can do like we were
supposed to be
when the vaccine was getting approved
they're like listen
we need to vaccinate a million people a
day
end of 2020 being of 2021 and it's like
is this really a reach goal like can't
we shoot for 2 million because at a
million people a day
if you need to do 720 million doses
because you know each person needs two
doses
are we just waiting for two years like
what the [ __ ] yeah
it's not good also i just don't like the
ideas of of like uh
this like hundred shots in a hundred
days like why does everything have to
sound like it's a used car
sales ad in this this freaking country
it's a 100 point plan
100 days yes start from step 100 go yeah
and then of course there's some states
where like they have just opened things
up so another
state we love to talk about is the state
of florida to be clear
i spent a big chunk of my childhood
there so i'm allowed to say bad things
about it um
alec as well spent time in florida he's
allowed to say bad things about it and
serbia's just allowed to say bad things
about it
um but in florida they basically opened
it up as a free-for-all which has led to
massive lines tons of disorganization is
that true
oh sorry free-for-all if you were 65 rep
not ever um
but you might imagine this might shock
people florida has a lot of people that
are 65 or over in it quite a few people
um and a lot of those people as well for
it has a lot of old
rich connected people as well so there's
been a lot of
line skipping sketchy activity confusion
about people getting it
um so thus far it's been i would i would
say i would rank
the the rollout on a scale of like super
chill to [ __ ] show
um mostly a [ __ ] show thus far and i
don't know about y'all
but i'm kind of i don't want to say
worried but i'm not super optimistic
moving forward so
what have you all been like feeling um
hearing reading thinking about the the
vaccination rollout thus far
i think it's a matter oh you can go i
know you go sorry so i think it's a bit
of a mess
um i don't anticipate being vaccinated
until the end of the year
unless something like crazy happens
um and i get it sooner but i
i mostly just want every all of the
health care workers
and the grocery store workers all of
them to get it
um my best friend from high school is a
doctor
and when she was vaccinated she sent me
a picture
of of it happening and i started to cry
it made me so happy and i realized how
stressed out i've been
thinking about her going to work and um
it felt like such a relief and so
i can't imagine how i'll feel when my
mom
and my grandparents and my brother and
like they all get vaccinated it'll be so
nice
yeah serbia let's do this as well so we
can look back on this episode
give me a as specific as you want when
do you think you will get a vaccine you
can give me a month you can give me a
date
november 2021. okay cool
we got november 21. um alex say whatever
you're going to say but start with that
when do you think if you had to put
money down you are getting the shot
optimistic me wants to say july 2021
pessimistic me so aggressive november
2022.
oh my god uh any anyone who's listening
who heard that just had a slight panic
attack
pause take ten deep breaths come back to
us what about you
burn um i would say
definitely quarter three 20 21
i kind of like that i i think maybe like
i'll say october i'll say october 2021
not because i'm trying to plan a wedding
in november but um
yeah i'll say october yeah
it's i mean a lot of it is obviously
the federal part of it's the federal
government doing nothing and like oh now
that the federal government wants to do
something is that going to be better but
also some of it's just like
like what the i i i hope this doesn't
sound like done in kruger where it's
like i feel like i
i could have done a better job doing
this and this isn't because i i have
some
know a lot about vaccine distributions
but because it's like so [ __ ] idiotic
uh in florida for instance uh the person
i know has a grandmother
uh who is trying to get vaccinated
doesn't live in one like nursing homes
or anything where
you know it's sort of taking care for
you and it's just a process of like oh
we heard publix the grocery store is
having them so i'm going to wake up at 6
00 a.m
her grandchildren and we're going to try
to like get on the website and it's
going to keep crashing well that didn't
work so we heard this other place has
and we have this other and so now i'm
like
texting people like hey i heard you got
out of this hospital like is this
hospital oh that hospital is out
and it's there's like a they're asking
you know
send an email to this email address and
you might get scheduled but there's like
no confirmation and also old people
don't know how to send emails so it's
like their whole life story like hi
i'm uh 75 turning 76 i was born and
raised in florida also i'd like a
vaccine please and it's like for the
love of god we just want your address
and date of birth
um and so that's one part of it and also
i was talking to a friend of mine who's
a pharmacist who is administering it
talking about how you know they're
trying to
you know get more people trained to to
vaccinate people including dentists
but even things like on a state level
that could be fixed
or even possibly coordinated this is in
new york i guess
individual healthcare facilities were
like here's how much vaccine we think we
need
so the place this person worked at
ordered too much and then the state had
to be like oh this hospital needs some
and you have too much so we're going to
take 500
you know vials or doses or whatever from
you and we're going to do it and so
i just when you're talking about you
know hundreds if not thousands of like
healthcare sites in a place like new
york and just expecting it to all work
out by being like i guess i need 200
doses and i guess they need 500
without some sort of like a [ __ ]
spreadsheet
you know i know we don't have a
centralized data healthcare record like
places in norway and the uk have i know
that makes things more difficult
but make a [ __ ] spreadsheet or google
doc google form
whatever or like broadway is better at
distributing their extra
broadway tickets with will call to
college students than we are about like
extra doses of vaccines yes
put the theater majors in charge of this
guys yeah like they
basically they should just have a thing
where it's like listen if you want a
vaccine show up at noon
and you might get a call at 5 p.m saying
that you've got an hour to make your way
down
to get this thing um you know this
friend was also talking about
you know the problem of wasting doses
you open a vial i think it's six hours
she said um and
also worried about getting in trouble
giving it to the sorts of wrong kinds of
people whereas other people in other
states are less worried and i've heard
friends say like oh i know someone who
knows someone who said if they have
extra doses they might call me and i can
show up at five which i don't i don't
even think it's a bad thing like
it'll be bad yeah i mean it would be bad
if it's like i got extra doses at the
end of the day give me 500
but as long as that's not happening and
it's just a [ __ ] nightmare and you
know i forget exactly how many weeks it
was but
new york city in the 40s or 50s had a
smallpox outbreak this is pre-computer
uh and they just were like [ __ ] it we're
vaccinating every single person
in the city of new york six million
people uh and they did it in a couple in
a matter of weeks and they
they averted it now granted it's a
little bit easier because they had were
able to
mass manufacture the the dosage but you
know if they can figure out how to
vaccinate everyone
once they have it like why can't we
distribute a couple million doses
so that's my rant yeah i wish that we
would put
put this in in the hands of people who
are accustomed to
um large-scale events or like
mobilizing like a significant number of
people and like moving them around
like the airline industry is really good
at that like
they're always like hurting people
around or like even the military is good
at like hurting
mass groups so like why can't we
speak to experts in that field like some
somebody in like logistics or like
project management to ask
how could we do this i feel like there
has to be transferable skills
that we can rely upon for this sort of
thing
yeah i agree i mean i think we should
use resources like the national guard
and whoever else to like have massive
uh public vaccination sites all over the
country
i do think you know alec you mentioned
this that you know some people have just
had to give out doses before it goes bad
and i've seen people get mad at that
i'll say this i encourage everyone to
remember this is not an individual
health problem it's a community health
problem
and as long as like you know we already
talked about
no one that you're listening to right
now thinks they're getting it anytime
soon but remember that like
i'm sorry i'm gonna sound corny now it
is better for everyone if those doses
get in people's arms no matter who they
are
as soon as possible because that's going
to stop the spread of this thing because
it is a community
health problem so don't be a hater don't
be mad don't get salty
if people get it before you it benefits
you i mean you listener
um if other people get it so just let's
at least try to have that mindset
and also tell old people in your life um
i know some of you i might be an old
person but i mean like real old people
tell them that when they get it they
still need to wear a mask and do all the
safe stuff it's a thing i'm worried
about with older people
i've talked to a few people i won't say
names who are old who think that when
they get it it's like a passport to play
um you know we still don't know if
people can can transfer it with the
vaccine so make the old people in your
life be smart get them pretty mask that
they'll wear just because they like the
the sort of uh stitching and the glitter
on them yeah god i love wearing a mask
yeah me too i i'm gonna wear them
forever um now
so let's move on to a related topic alec
um i guess you're here to tell people in
l.a
how they should live or use your east
coast bias
to lay harsh criticism on los angeles
just like a good new york times writer
would
i kid um but but tell us about why
things are so bad where i live and why i
have to be terrified to get groceries
yeah i don't know if you you knew this
michael burns but uh
the coronavirus as it's called is real
bad in la
i keep hearing worst in the world but i
actually don't know if that's true
uh i don't know if that's per capita per
death whatever it's a [ __ ] nightmare
and i
uh do and don't understand because on
one
one hand at the beginning of the
pandemic we were roasting like oh all
these stupid [ __ ] governors have this
outbreak and they're not like shutting
down their cities
and then in la and in new york we're
having a very strong second
uh resurgence and they're like oh well
we're not gonna like shut down gyms that
seems you know that seems extreme
so there's that but anyway the the
article i wanna talk about is in box
it's called los angeles it's america's
new coronavirus hot spot urban sprawl
might have played a role
uh early on in the pandemic there was uh
you know obviously
new york where i live was the the bad
place to be
a lot a lot of people died mass graves
it was not a good time
uh people including myself uh
attributed it not not irrationally to
like hey it's a city
you have people taking you have hundreds
of people you know crammed into subway
cars
every day millions of riders crammed
individually hundreds at a time into
subway cars
you know in offices passing people on
the sidewalk obviously it is the
concentration of people that
has made new york so bad and that was
kind of the assumption
now fast forward six months or a year
later and there's huge outbreaks in very
rural areas
um la which is still a city but it's not
quite as as
concentrated in new york is obviously uh
doing much much worse
and so the article kind of talks about
how that breaks down a little bit
that's not to say again new york is not
doing so hot right now either but i
think la is much worse
um so the article talks to one jennifer
jane rowe who's the director of the
university of virginia center for design
and health
argues that one of the specific problems
of la is
the urban sprawl and car culture people
in los angeles and other commentators
everywhere like listen
you get in the car in la you go
somewhere you're protected you don't
have to share buses with strangers
obviously this is it
but there's like a weird kind of uh
symptom of that which is because of the
car culture in la
i guess it's one of the most park poor
areas there's just not green spaces to
hang out
um uh roe talks about how people feel
isolated and alienated you know the only
way to see people is you drive to
basically not a shopping mall but like
some strip mall and go place and have
drinks
there's not a place for you to have a
picnic outdoors with your friends
there's not
a sense of community uh and and so it's
very hard on people's mental health
and i just thought it was a really
interesting way to look at the
spread of disease in that light
specifically in just like what does the
spread of disease mean
when you have no parks and is that
applicable to other things that aren't
coronavirus like if there was
you know another influenza outbreak or
tuberculosis or anything like that
uh what do you think i mean i just as
the
the perspective of a los angeles
resident i mean i think a lot of those
points are apt and it was weird that
early on the logic was
you know oh we're good because people
take cars and not to train and bus
and now it's like for some of those same
reasons we're screwed but yeah the lack
of public space in this city is
abhorrent
um near where i live there's one like
kind of fancy neighborhood that has wide
medians between the roads that's just a
bunch of grass
and people have turned that into like a
makeshift park and they have like
picnics and hang out there which is
great like i like to see people
occupying green space but there's very
few places to hang out because of how
expensive real estate is here
i have like two people i know that have
actual good outdoor space in their house
so when things did feel safer like those
were the only people i saw because we
could hang out safely in their backyards
um but yeah i mean it does feel like
that and i know as well i don't know if
this came up in that article but
something i've read about a bit
is housing density is also a problem in
los angeles where
a lot of people live together have
roommates live with a bunch of family
and a lot of households
you might have two people that have to
go to work every day
and three people that don't and maybe
those people that have to go to work
have to take the bus to their
retail job or their job or whatever so
it also sounds like that's been a
problem but
it has felt weird on the ground here
wondering why things have gotten so bad
um yeah survey so
researchers say that there is a new
strain
of covet in l.a wait but this is the
special california one not the uk one
right yeah
this is totally separate from the uk one
is the one that came from brazil
or is that there's so many mutant
strains now i don't know which is which
i didn't read anything about brazil in
this article but they were saying that
i forget the percentage but it was
something like
i don't know i'm just going to make
something up like 40 percent of the
people at cedars-sinai
have this specific strain um and so
they're saying that it could be like
super contagious or something and that
could contribute to why
la has just exploded in terms of covet
cases
yeah i mean and the other thing too with
la that one has to remember is that
you can go to a shopping mall here like
i'm not supposed to
see anyone or hang out with a friend or
go in any enclosed space but i wanted to
go to like
lids or forever 21 or claire's
um or banana republic i could go to one
of those places right now in an indoor
shopping center
if i wanted because that's considered to
be some sort of a priority
um you know dining is shut down
completely no outdoor dining or whatever
but
one can go to the shopping mall certain
gyms are open at capacity i think
go-kart tracks are still
open um so there's also been this
sort of disconnect between what we know
and what we're doing and what feels
really weird too is like
and this seems to be the case all over
the country is that the same type of
like basically the numbers are
so much worse now than they were when
things really were locked down yeah
so i do worry and i know people talk
about covet fatigue and all this sort of
stuff
it does feel and maybe this connects a
bit with our last topic
like because of covid fatigue and
because of people just kind of being
like oh well the vaccine's coming so
whatever
it feels like large swaths of society
have given up which really bums me out
and i wish someone would carton arc them
um but am i being too pessimistic do we
think that that's part of it at all that
people
along with all of this have the the lazy
los angeles hippies just given up
i i think on a personal level there is
obviously fatigue
but also governmental fatigue i mean
again it's the you know bill de blasio
and andrew cuomo shut down new york city
for two weeks at the beginning
now the numbers seem about on par
although the deaths aren't nearly the
same so maybe it was just under reported
back then or something like that
and you know i think i think we shut
down indoor dining again but
but we're not really
it seems like why aren't we doing the
two-week thing
and especially in l.a and so i feel like
maybe governors
and mayors are saying people are tired
of this and they will
riot or something if we try it again we
don't have the money to do it or
something like that but also on a
personal level i do
you know i was much more cautious um
in whatever that was march or april
basically not leaving the house for days
at a time whereas now
i'm just like listen i really need to go
for a walk and like
i've been told that you know in general
15 minutes of exposure
like for a case to transmit it's often
15 minutes of exposure
uh to a person with covid so i'm like if
i go and get this coffee for two like
you know
two minutes like it's not it's safe and
i would have never said that i'm not
saying that's the right answer i'm not
saying i should be doing that but i'm
just like
you know obviously been a very cautious
person for
a year uh so that's where i'm at
have either of y'all felt yourselves
getting re-cautious
recently i only asked it because i've
kind of felt like a return
swinging back towards that where i got a
little lax for a bit sorby have you felt
that
yeah i did so i was super cautious in
the beginning
and then i think maybe towards like
august or september
i like chilled out a little bit um
but then when cases started to resurge
again
in like september october i ramped it
back up
um and so i do feel like
people do look a little like do look at
me a little strangely like when they see
me outside like
washing my milk bottle or like doing
certain things like really like that's a
little extreme
but i feel like it it makes me feel more
comfortable and if there's like one
small chance that i can get covered from
the surface of a bag of chips i would
rather wash it and look like an idiot
than
have my grandparents die like it's not
about me like if i get covered i
don't care but like i see my
grandparents and i don't want them to
die they're in their 80s so
i just feel like i'd rather be overly
cautious and
enjoy myself yeah i
i'm more cautious in some ways but in
other ways
i i'm just very easily able to
rationalize
what i want to do uh and as many people
are and so it's like
oh i want to be more cautious so i'm not
going to go in the bagel place because
there's like often a lot of people in
there
and the owner i think is from staten
island
oh boy staten island's real bad with the
coven numbers and also oh really
yeah um so there's that but i will again
like go into the other place with the
shittier bagels because it's like okay
like it's actually very spacious and
there's only ever one person in there
and i again
six months ago or eight months ago i
would not have done that so i'm
rationalizing one but but not the other
and so that's where i'm at but i'm not
i'm not at earlier on the pandemic where
like
you know wash your groceries you know if
you i obviously should still wash your
hands but but you know
the serbi method i based on what i've
read i was like i don't think i need to
do that
uh and i'm not doing it again i have
yeah i haven't gone back to that i was a
full-on like leaving things in the car
or not touching bags
wiping things like there was the plague
on them and i've chilled out in that
regard
but i told you that yeah but i'm back to
like i don't know
i'm like double masking if i have to go
in any like
uh confined space i'm trying to like
mostly just buy
groceries like a farmer's market so i
can be outside
and not have to go inside and be around
people but yeah it sucks um it sucks
real bad
and hopefully anyone else who's
listening to this who thinks suck real
bad for we feel you especially if you're
in la but wherever you are
um but if you're in l.a especially alec
told you why you're bad
and why he's superior being a
new yorker wow um anything else you want
to get into on that one alec
that's it awesome so um
for our final the but most fun topic of
the day i actually mean this
this one's actually a little fun serbia
you're going to talk to us
about a wide-ranging topic but we're
going to start with the curious case of
hilaria slash hillary baldwin
wife of alec baldwin who who has me
blocked on twitter so i missed a lot of
this debate
um who has you blocked on twitter alec
baldwin
really i don't know why i probably just
like called him a chode once in the
replies and he
did that um but tell us about this story
i know i'm sure a lot of people heard of
this some people might not have
um why was everyone talking about
hilaria baldwin last week
okay so hilary baldwin wife of alec
baldwin has spent
quite a bit of time talking about how
she's from
spain um she said that she came to the
states when she was 19 to attend
university she's appeared in magazines
focused on latinas
uh she's done interviews to discuss her
experiences as a spanish american woman
she was once on a talk show doing like a
cooking segment and she picked up a
cucumber and was like oh what is this
called
and they're like oh it's a cucumber and
she goes ah right yes cucumber
um and she's talked about how she was
raised and born in mallorca
and she speaks with a very very strong
spanish accent
um basically hilaria has been
presenting herself as spanish for years
and
a few weeks ago she was in the news
after
someone tweeted about her decade-long
grift to deceive people into believing
she's from spain
apparently ilaria from mallorca is
actually
hillary from massachusetts and
when this all came out as a lie
she was con she she appeared very
baffled why people would believe that
she's from spain
even though her wedding to alec baldwin
was steeped in
spanish culture spanish was spoken at
the wedding ceremony
she said see at the end um
and she gave interviews talking about
how she
liked that she brought her culture into
the wedding also alec baldwin has given
several interviews saying that his wife
is from spain
um and the response to this has been
overwhelmingly
negative people are disturbed that she
faked not only her accent
but also her life she presented herself
as an immigrant
she talked about how people at the park
believe that she's the nanny because her
children are
blonde with uh blue eyes and they
believe that because she's spanish she
has to be the nanny
um and it brought up
sorry even the lie is so stupid because
like
she's she's pretending to be a minority
in america
by identifying as like a white european
lady i i don't know
like i get like oh like americans are so
dumb and stupid they see like a white
person from spain and be like obviously
they're latino
yeah it's it's strange on multiple
aspects so
um her story brought up other
conversations about other celebrities
who have also faked accents like lindsay
lohan
and madonna wait what what did they fake
what alec sorry i don't know this you
don't know madonna's fake
uh english accent you know madonna from
detroit the singer
oh i guess she does kind of talk with
like uh
no she she's stopped now but when she
was married to guy richie
it was she sounded like a fake english
person
it was wild it was so weird and she's
given interviews
now saying i don't know why i did that
she's like i think
i think she said guy richie made me do
it or something
the lohan one is all time though i think
lindsay lohan is very
fake tell me the lindsay lohan one so
lindsay lohan has this like very strange
like it just sounds like an
accent like i would call it like
pan-european yeah
it's nothing but it's everything it's
it's like
french and english and spanish it's like
it's just everything
a little like greek accent on certain
things
yeah it's in my mind this is like the
mom from shit's creek
that like weird happening a little bit
like that but like
more intense except a real person and
not a character actor on a comedic
sitcom
dude
um yeah she's and she said that it's
happened because she lives a very
international lifestyle
um and so this conversation
uh started to go towards how celebrities
will make themselves appear more
international and more
unique and what was fascinating to me is
that
celebrities live a unique life in
comparison to most people and so they
don't need to
fake accents or have fake names and a
dishonest background to appear
interesting and it just made me think
like who are they trying to
impress and like what are they trying to
achieve and
i think it's like a self-esteem or a
self-confidence issue that
maybe they're so desperate to be to be
better than their peers or
um to be more unique even though they're
already unique
so it's strange and fascinating and
disturbing and
i'd love to know what the two of you
think about people inventing
especially celebrities not just like
people like us but celebrities inventing
a life or faking an accent i don't
necessarily
i don't know much about hillary baldwin
but i wouldn't necessarily say because
they're celebrities they're unique
if anything like let's just say you know
you're you're married to an al baldwin
type but you know obviously you're no
gwyneth paltrow or leonardo dicaprio you
know you're not
top dollar celebrity um and it's like
being famous is weird because it's not
necessarily a thing you do
it's just like this amorphous quality of
of being famous
and likability and [ __ ] like that and so
you know i i know nothing about her
hillary baldwin
hilaria whatever uh but
you know like if you live in this vapid
culture about like attention and you
don't really have anything to go off of
because you're not like a concert
pianist or
you don't aren't like an amazing actor
or something like that
yeah you make something up and i think
that
in american culture generally there's
this weird thing that's happened where
we as a nation are like very obviously
interested in talking about like lots of
our issues including
uh racism and identity and stuff like
that but there's like a weird backlash
that where everyone who
uh is like white and middle class needs
to feel like they need some traumatic
story about
how their great-great-great-grandfather
was native american and
died from smallpox or you know uh i may
be
white middle-class but at one time
somebody
called me the f-word or something like
that and so
culturally i i think there's like this
weird
symptom of lots of things going on in
america where people like hillary
baldwin
feel that like to be interesting or
valued they need to
basically uh portray themselves as
some oppressed figure i also think this
is true of the translate racial lady
rachel dalzahl
where she wasn't she like a mediocre uh
writer but then she started writing
about like african diaspora or she made
art or something like that and then
you know started you know basically
doing blackface so i don't know i i
think we live in a weird world where
that's for some people the obvious
reaction to
a nation that is trying to come to terms
with some things
yeah i think that's well put sort of
this like desire
for otherness and exceptionalization um
and i think it is kind of like cooked
into us because i remember being in like
fourth or fifth grade and we had to do
like family culture day and present on
where our ancestors were from
something too that looks increasingly
tone deaf when
i mean in my school there were a lot of
black students
and and like a few native students and
you know it's not like
fun when you come from an oppressed
culture to be like where were my family
doing like three or four generations ago
it's not like they were like
cobblers in italy for some people that
goes back to colonization oppression
slavery all this sort of stuff
um but we're taught to think that that's
like this cute part of ourselves and
even the way that people
uh will identify as like blank american
like italian-american irish-american to
be clear like when i say i'm irish
american it's a bit so it's okay when i
do it but
um but this desire to possess some sort
of otherness and not just be
a sort of like grab bag american
um and i think especially when it comes
to people that are celebrities or
and i don't mean to like dis cause i
don't know a lot about her background
but
would we say that hillary baldwin is
more like celebrity adjacent
was she like an actor or performer or
anything pre-marriage to
one of the worst irish americans who's
ever been i don't think so
but since then she's been trying to do
like podcasts
yeah and then you know not to [ __ ] on
this person for her career stuff but it
does seem like a case where wow well i
have to
have to find a way to exceptionalize now
that i'm married to america's prince
alec baldwin
um just a real bad guy too in case
anyone doesn't remember there was
voicemails where he called his daughter
like a fat [ __ ] pig when she was like
12 years old because he's a good guy
yeah i don't i never forget about how
baldwin's a total piece of [ __ ]
same thing with mel gibson never forget
what he do what do you do
i'm kidding he's just kidding i'm
kidding i'm kidding he's the worst i'm
totally kidding of course
yeah but no but i think it's it's really
it's an unfortunate
cultural thing and i've even thought
about this like if i ever have kids
i don't want to do the thing where it's
like well this grandparents from here in
this great grand rapids i'm gonna be
like sorry kid this sucks you're just
like an american deal with it this
country is what it is
you're not some like special all goes
west story you're just a person that's
born in this country
yeah there's i want to say uh
like a tangential connection in just
like again like i'm not necessarily
criticizing the behavior but
um there was like an uh an author who
was a
admissions officer or professor or
something like that
who reads uh applications to a college
or a writing program or something like
that and you know
in those essays students basically need
to sell themselves as interesting
and a lot of times like kids go back to
like their oppression and trauma like
you know
and again not that this is necessarily
bad or they they shouldn't be allowed to
talk about this stuff but you know like
i grew up in a rough neighborhood and
like dealt with racism my whole life
like that kind of stuff
um but this professor uh or whoever was
who was like a victim of sexual assault
uh and was very traumatized by it
is now finding that like over the
overwhelming majority
or just like an overwhelming amount of
application essays
focus on like women and their sexual
trauma and
the point wasn't to say like oh stop
this but like it's weird for me
to basically be re-traumatized
to have to bring this up but also for
this like social pressure
for people to feel that they need to
sort of disclose it to get into school
and for some people it might be
cathartic but also
it's just i i'm basically i'm not trying
to sort of demonize the behavior but
also be like there's a there's
some weird things going on there you
know yeah
we need to bring a psychoanalyst on here
to psychoanalyze
our culture for all of this weird stuff
yeah um
serbia any more thoughts on on this
topic and the
hilarious debacle of hilarious
baldwin i know i should i this is my
last time hosting i've just got fired
for that line
her accent has disappeared interesting
or okay
um and i think alec baldwin went off
twitter too not that i know that he like
suspended his account maybe i'll be
allowed to see him again when he comes
back
i i will say once i shared a
elevator with alec baldwin and i'm
pretty sure he's talking about my orca
and i never connected the dots but for
some reason i remembered
that he was talking about my orca
because i like had just learned what it
was or something like that
amazing i just this is just to decide
but
i find it incredible when celebrities
lie about things because
it's going to come out people know who
you are it's not like i can lie and be
like i have a dog and nobody's gonna
know
like people went to school with you
people grew up with you what do you
think no one's gonna talk
yeah oh the other great example of like
wanting to
be victimized is the guy from the league
who lied about being in one of the twins
yes for 9 11. i forget his name
mark randanzo or something like that
uh yeah just the worst what
but it was more of a like somehow it got
out there he's like i just never
corrected people and i shouldn't have i
shouldn't have done that
yeah so serbian for anyone else that's
this sort of
comic actor he's been on the show called
the league talked about how he was in
one of the buildings
when 9 11 happened and he like ran out
and was like running through the streets
it turns out he was not there
he was nowhere near there and it like
ruined his career
and one of the things he tried to do to
get back in the game at one point was
did like the jeffrey ross
roast battle on comedy central and the
comedian he was matched up against just
immediately
went in for him lined up in 9 11 and it
was just like done
over i want to watch that yeah
so you know real take away here don't
lie about stuff be who you are
and let your talents abilities and and
kindness and compassion
be what define you um speaking of
kindness
and compassion this is a horrible
transition
we love to hear from you kind and
compassionate listeners so um
as always uh we want to hear what you
have to think about any of this if you
have any good stories about celebrities
do a fake things like this if you have
insights on vaccinations
uh anything like that uh hit us up you
can call us at 213-534-8807 that is
213-534-8807
or email us culturebench at
wisecrack.com nope there was no m there
just co
culture binge wisecrack dot co
um so let's hear i think we have i think
we have one voicemail maybe a couple
emails
um so let's let's get into that yeah uh
the first one is an
e a voicemail from ross if we could play
that
hey culture bins this is ross from dc uh
really enjoyed
this past episode i wanted to weigh in a
little bit on y a
now the genre itself independent of
the opinions of their authors like sort
of like
outside of what they're writing about is
really instructive for
students i am a high school english
teacher i thought 10th grade for a while
and then i taught 11th grade i teach at
title 1 school many of my students have
english as a second language
or they are several grades below reading
level
um in tracking a person's reading
development
often the progression goes from strong
plot
to being drawn to character to being
drawn to theme
and then being drawn to sort of the
technicalities of writing so how an
author is writing
and so what why it does really well
especially for students who are like
right around the 8th to 10th grade
reading level
is it engages them on the level of
character
so that they can feel invested to
eventually talk about greater themes
now one of my enjoyments for reading
literature of all kinds
is that all of those different levels
sort of
accumulate as i've grown and so
if i read a book that has a great plot
that has great characters
that explores an incredible theme and
then lastly
like is written beautifully holy crap
that's just like a grand slam of a book
but to get there i have to kind of like
ascend the ladder
and so yes some oia may be like emily in
paris and it's sort of light
and i don't have to think about it when
it's over but for the
people who it's reaching it's activating
their reading abilities at a level that
gets them primed for the
next step up and so i just wanted to
sort of like weigh in with my teacher
perspective at least my high school
teacher perspective
i love the work that you do uh thank you
so much for
um keeping this going um definitely
keeping us going during this pandemic so
we appreciate you all
and serbia is always still waiting on
that mukbang take care
yeah yeah um i like ross from dc
he's emailed in a couple times he's the
best and just shouts to ross in general
for being a teacher that's
in my humble opinion the best thing you
can do they're the best people we should
pay them a million dollars a year
but that's really interesting that's
cool to hear that perspective on on how
useful y a can be
yeah like a gateway drug into literacy
literature all those sorts of things i
feel like going from theme to
technicality is that just a transition
i've made just this last year i don't
think that's actually true but it might
be
yeah ross can you email us with book
recommendations
yeah uh it also reminds me just
uh jk rowling's many things but
like the world of harry potter i i think
is good
uh some might say the themes are good
but on a technical level of writing it's
just [ __ ] awful it's so bad how i
learned how to write
uh i just want to note i said nothing
about jk rowling good or bad because i
just don't want anyone to be mad at me
but alec
did say that she was a terrible writer
implying that if you like harry potter
that you
have a trash brain you know it's really
bad like uh i
went through like i just read like four
books on writing back to back and
when i was like huh it seems like uh all
these things you're not supposed to do
she does and then one author was just
like none of these rules are tried and
true
for instance this thing about like using
adverbs and writing dialogue uh you
could still become
a billionaire uh writer her name is jk
rowling by breaking all those rules so
what the [ __ ] do i know and i think that
was the best writing advice i've ever
received
wow also writing rules are slightly
overrated sometimes but
okay um we got i think that was the only
voicemail right yeah yeah
uh so emails yeah emails and one more
time culture binge at wisecrack.co
uh write us in we read them all even if
we can't read them on the show but this
one's from evan
uh since you covered virtual dating in
your last podcast i was wondering if
you'd review my tinder bumble profile
the written part not the pictures evan i
want the pictures
not to be creepy as you might not want
unsolicited picks
uh anyway the profile is below even
though it was disney movies in there i
wasn't one of the people who gave you
grief for that
thank you evan i enjoyed that episode of
the podcast ps again it's in four
sections since i couldn't decide what to
include
so here we are we are going to live
critique
whoa yeah uh and we're
running a little bit of time so i'm not
sure how many other i think we should
really spend our time on this
even at the expense of other emails i
apologize to everyone else
alright so here it is evan's profile
share my hoodies question mark yes share
my fries question mark
maybe winky face i can't fix your daddy
issues but i can
call you one build a deck two rocker ron
swanson mustache three make
inappropriate dad jokes
four call you sport and pick you up when
you're drunk i'm someone who is never
gonna give you up never gonna let you
down never gonna run around because i
have asthma so i'm bad at running uh
line break 70s music nerdy stuff disney
movie disney movies acro yoga swing
dance rock climbing
and profile i've got a lot of thoughts
on this
i think we all do the last part i liked
best i'll say just the the list of
activities
yeah um i although i think we all
reacted to this and once again i like
what's what's this person's name again
evan
evan first of all the vulnerability
you're showing right here i want you to
know i respect that online dating is
scary
um if my partner never leaves me i'm
going to be alone for the rest of my
life because i don't know if i have any
online dates so take everything
that we will say with that um you got to
lose the daddy issues thing because that
that comes off as kind of like
potentially you know a little a little
patronizing
um so i would say remove that would be
my first thing i say we just cut that
right off the bat yeah so
um seeing as i'm uniquely qualified for
this
yes
i say you should get rid of everything
before you list your activities um
because the ron swanson the like
all that stuff like we don't need any of
that like we don't need to know that
you're gonna call me sport
if i'm fall down or whatever like that
the more interesting thing is what you
like to do
though nobody's gonna get past the intro
um my friend will drink a glass of wine
and get on tinder
and she'll screenshot tender profiles
you're gonna give the poor guy anxiety
don't tell her no
i'm just saying that the number one
thing that we will roast guys about is
if they talk about daddy issues
like it's immediate like you're an
[ __ ] no one's gonna go on a date with
you
like i i guarantee nobody sees that and
is like yeah this guy sounds like the
one for me
yeah i think that's fair and maybe
they've had like limited success
by like a certain person who's not but
i'm just saying for every one success
that that maybe that works on you're
shut you're disqualified from like 50
women
um i i i sent this to
the two i know two women uh one of them
is my partner
one of them i know two women sorry
um and uh on the first part
i i think there's well i have specific
thoughts one is like the rock of ron
swanson mustache there's an old rule in
writing speaking writing rules which is
show don't tell
you got a picture with ron swanson
mustache you don't need to tell people
that you have it
uh obviously you know some women
historically have liked my facial hair
you'll almost never hear me talking
about it
so but but fine people like ron swanson
mustaches show don't tell
i think the building a deck is cool but
i do wonder and i
this i talked about this with with
another
woman who you know is interested in men
uh i think that might be like a good
thing to like
it's almost like you bit want to bury
the lead you want to like bring that up
a day like oh by the way like i know how
to build decks because
that is super [ __ ] cool um and also
someone i know uh thought it was
charming the
the uh pick you up when you're drunk you
know it's like a nice like i'm not an
[ __ ] thing serbia disagrees obviously
women are gonna
disagree uh you know about what their
sort of verboten kind of lines are do
you
disagree with that serbia besides just
the call you sport and pick you up when
you're drunk
i just don't know that that's what i
would include in a dating profile
like i think there's another way to
describe that sentiment that you are
like you'll take care like you'll look
after somebody but i feel like that
doesn't need to be
you don't need to broadcast that in the
profile yeah two quick thoughts on this
one would be i think the kiss method
works really well for dating profiles
and that doesn't mean you just smooch
them
um but they keep it simple stupid thing
right i think a simple profile is the
best
and you know like like serbia said a lot
of times people
are sadly because of our consumer's
mindset are swiping through dating
profiles as if they're looking at like
you know items on a retail website so
you got to be kind of quick and punchy
the other thing i'll say though is it's
it is a numbers game and something that
might come off as like
corny or stupid or whatever to some
people some people might like a lot and
you're not out here trying to i don't i
don't know what your vision is
but you're you're not trying to appeal
to everyone you're trying to appeal to
people
that that will like you and you'll like
them and you'll have similar interests
so you know sometimes you do have to
like take a swing
knowing that someone might think it's
ridiculous but someone
might like it that's what i agree with
with everything my esteemed colleagues
are saying here but you know
i wouldn't want this person to do you to
hear our advice and think that it has to
be this completely streamlined vanilla
thing
do you be you but just you know think
about how this stuff looks
when it's when it's hitting someone's
screen yeah and i i think that's why the
interests are good because
no matter who you are and what your
interests are and you have cool interest
uh
swing dance sounds rad rock climbing
yeah uh acro
if acro yoga is like the thing with the
floating around from the god tapestries
i'm using all the wrong words but that's
no pictures of holding fish i think dude
shouldn't hold fish pictures
on dating profiles there's a whole
account that's like dudes holding fish
on tinder
or like sitting next to drugged tigers
that's enough yeah no drugstores take it
down
or joe exotic if you have a picture with
joe exotic do not post it
but but i think the interests are good
because also you know like a lot of
times what people want to partner
someone with similar at least compatible
interest and so like
again if my partner left me i'd probably
be forever alone like michael
but i might be looking for someone with
like the words like hiking in the
profile because i like hiking and
reading and maybe like what kind of
books and
uh maybe i'll get super judgy about that
so so i think that's a good place
to be but also i think you should uh put
your profile name is ignacio and claim
you're from mallorca
people will find it way more interesting
that's a profile
not a serial killer and then have your
bio be
i'm a lot of things but a serial killer
isn't one of them tell me what size
shoes you have i love feet but i'm not a
serial killer let's go out at night in a
home depot parking lot yes
i think they i so here's the thing if if
i had just read evan's interest
i would have swiped right and been like
i i want to learn more about swing
dancing
like that he sounds like a great guy um
i would have swiped right on that but
the beginning part is what
why i wouldn't have yeah so would you
say condense so we're getting to the
interest as quick as possible with a
light
intro i would say do a light intro
that's like
something very genuine like what people
will respond to is human connection and
so if you're just like a normal
person who's like hi i'm evan like
really hope we're a good fit for each
other here's what i like to do something
that's just like very simple even simple
like that and then you list your
interests i'd be
more interested in that and then see
your
humor and personality while we're
chatting and when we meet up
yeah and if you want to match with
serbia set your zip code to
uh but yeah uh best of luck evan
thank you for the vulnerability of
trusting that that's that's really cool
and and hopefully you don't take any of
this
harshly if anyone else wants to do it
now that we're really good at this um
you know
send us these things i am an expert yeah
our our last email of the day
is from uh luke about disney plus
content sent us a really interesting
email
uh i'm so glad you guys discussed the
new disney plus content to be released
over the next few years as you had a
similar conversation
you had a similar conversation that i
had with my wife i worry that disney is
going
towards quantity over quality in order
to get the prestige of established
stream
platforms unfortunately the streaming
business is dominated by what
the economist called netflix anomics
this model is based on having frequent
new content and understanding a viewer's
tendencies to push content to them
uh that would likely enjoy that they
would likely enjoy netflix knows that
their
subscribers can't watch everything so
they try to tailor the original content
to everyone's flavor of the week
ironically by sample
sampling taste clusters of 2 000 viewers
in hopes that they won't pay attention
to competitors
this model and streaming general have
completely turned the law of diminishing
returns
as alex mentioned it's not but i still
love you uh on
itself since movie producers can use
their algorithms
to target this mass quantity of movies
towards people who are more likely to
watch and enjoy it
a failing movie or show is no longer a
huge deal since it costs less due to
niche audiences
disney seems to be going full speed
ahead mimicking this model which leads
me to believe
that only a few of the star wars marvel
properties will be really good and the
rest will be
good to specific groups if netflix is
the model then likely
means this is the future of television
yeah i i think it's a really cool email
i think
uh i will say wandavision a marvel
property it's on my maybe this is
quantity over quality but we'll see if
i'm wrong don't send me hate mail please
yeah that's a really insightful email
just a agreement all around
yeah yeah
cool well so very weird
awkward pause there sorry for that
awkward edit edit that no that was just
a great email we agree with you thank
you for that insight um and yes i think
that is the worry with disney plus and
as of right now
unless you're really into star wars or
marvel or you're a child
not probably the best streaming service
um
but if you don't want to email but you
just want to quickly give
us takes by by hitting us up on social
media to tell us why we're wrong
how can people do that serbia where can
people find you don't give don't give
them your zip code though
sorry patel 22 on twitter alec
uh i'm at wisecrack alec nice i'm
michael o'burns and now my
account is reinstated after it got
locked because someone reported a tweet
from six years ago
um
yeah man um don't joke about never mind
i won't even say it
um but so hit us up we would love to
hear from you there
um and of course once again wisecrack
dot co 213-534-8807
we will be back with you in two weeks so
hopefully some exciting and positive
things happen between now and then
and we will we'll see you there later
guys
[Music]
you